vingt ans de prison ferme et près de 7
millions d'euros d'amendés pour
guillaume soro l'ex premier ministre de
la côte d'ivoire jugé hier en son
absence à abidjan l'ancien chef de la
rébellion ivoirienne exil en france et
condamné pour recel de détournements
publics et blanchiment de capitaux dans
le cadre de l'achat de sa maison il ya
treize ans il était alors le chef du
gouvernement
malgré sa condamnation guillaume soro
reste candidat les jeux présidentielle
en octobre prochain
ils dénoncent ce site une condamnation
politique démenti de l'avocat de l'état
ivoirien
cette décision être la mort d'une
nouvelle ère en côte d'ivoire il faut
traquer les corrompus
partout où il se trouvera alors que
notre état puisque conforme à ses
engagements à savoir la lutte contre la
corruption
cher à nos clients et à la côte d'ivoire
vous avez constaté à l'audience avec les
différents témoignages les pièces du
dossier que des fonds ont été
effectivement détourné au préjudice
l'état de côte-d'ivoire
sauf mauvaise foi on ne peut pas avoir
un seul en ce procès une quelconque
volonté politique